los encuestadores hablan de que se
espera una participación entre el 40 y
45 por ciento por tratarse de una
elección regional y no presidencial sin
embargo hay mayor trascendencia en estas
elecciones regionales y es porque tal y
como lo decías la oposición no
participaba desde el 2017 aunque ahora
también va a fraccionar a estos comicios
se pronunciaba a través de las redes
sociales juan guaidó y aseguraba que no
serán unas elecciones libres y justas
pero que respetaba a los partidos
políticos de oposición que sí decidieron
acudir henrique capriles de dos veces
candidato presidencial también se
pronuncia diciendo estas elecciones no
legitiman a maduro por el contrario lo
que queremos es recuperar la elección en
el voto y lograr que tengan voces en
todo el país los distintos alcaldes y
gobernadores pues actualmente la mayoría
de las alcaldías y las gobernaciones se
encuentran a manos del chavismo y maduro
lo tomaba también como un acto de ir a
votar en contra del imperialismo y de
las sanciones que han impuesto a
venezuela es también trascendente el
hecho de que participe la observación
internacional por primera vez como lo
decías desde hace 15 años una misión de
la unión europea